[Musique]
entretien politique avec Martin lévrier
sénateur renaissance des Yvelines
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur donc
on va on va parler du Sénat évidemment
parce que peut-être que les gens ne
savent pas exactement comment ça
fonctionne je disais dans une interview
qui accordait Pierre Rosanvallon qui est
un des grands politologues que au fond
dans cette période où on aurait pu
penser qu'une assemblée sans majorité
allait fonctionner autrement c'est
plutôt le Sénat qui a profité de cette
période et c'est vrai quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé sur la loi de
retraite ou il y a eu des
destinations ça rassemblé qui n'est pas
grandiose le Sénat semblait mieux
travailler c'est votre sentiment aussi
alors oui sur la sur la réforme des
retraites il est très clair que le un
véritable travail a pu être fait au
Sénat et un vrai travail j'allais dire
presque de coalition alors en amont d'un
travail avec les la majorité du Sénat
qui qui est représenté par la
républicains et les centres
importants et nous-mêmes où on a pu un
vrai travail en amont un travail de
conciliation ou de controverse qui a
construit un consensus positif avec des
évolutions de la loi très importante et
de cette de ce travail qui a été fait à
l'hémicycle une loi est sortie Stéphane
proposition de loi de sortie
effectivement qui avait un véritable
sens et qui a été présenté en CMP c'est
à dire le regroupement ça c'est la
commission municipale pardon vous avez
cette sénateurs et cette députés qui
travaillent la loi pour essayer de
trouver un chemin commun qui serait voté
normalement à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat
donc ce travail en amont a été fait a
été très bien fait avec un véritablement
un vrai travail républicain j'allais
dire de réflexion profonde sur cette loi
au Sénat même au niveau de l'hémicycle
ce qui est une deuxième partie de la
chose une fois que c'est amendements
sont proposés etc les amendements dont
sont présentés à l'hémicycle et là
malheureusement on a retrouvé la même
forme de comportement de blocage en tout
cas de la part de la dupeesse voilà non
pas alors la droite le centre et nous
avons fait notre travail et les
amendements qui que nous estimons
positifs pour améliorer la loi on a
réussi à les faire passer mais en
revanche il y a eu une logique de
blocage terrible de la part de la
nupesse entre guillemets c'est à dire
les socialistes les communistes et les
Verts qui ont tout fait pour que le
débat n'arrive pas à la fin d'accord de
la même façon enfin de façon inversée
donc jusqu'à l'article 7 il y avait une
forme d'engagement entre les présidents
de groupe de dire l'article 7 on attend
le 7 le jour du 7 c'était le jour de la
grande manifestation et on le votera ce
soir là donc on a joué le jeu de la
patience au niveau de la majorité pour
attendre ce mardi le 7 ça a été voté et
là à notre grande surprise la nuit pêche
a continué son construction en ajoutant
au fur et à mesure que nous avançons des
amendements et des sous amendements et
on a vu le monde on n'irait pas au bout
de cette de ce travail sur la loi qui
est notre travail nous sommes quand même
des élus pour faire des lois non pas
pour faire de l'obstruction mais au
Sénat nous sommes allés au bout nous
avons réussi et malheureusement la suite
c'est moins bien terminé
d'une façon générale c'est vrai que je
disais il y a cette assemblée sont
majorité absolue enfin les députés sont
majorité absolue donc on avait pu bosser
un moment qui aurait des négociations
etc qui aurait une une culture du
compromis est-ce que le Sénat le Sénat
est plus habitué à ça cette culture-là
est plus habituée je crois que j'ai
j'essaie de donner un peu une image de
la représentation et de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat qui qu'on le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale les les
députés sont élus directement par le
peuple et dans ils sont en direct en
confrontation directe avec le peuple
donc dans une logique parfois de
caractère d'urgence nous sénatum nous
sommes élus par les grands électeurs
donc
monde un peu de député est-ce que c'est
pas parce que on dit souvent parce que
parfois ils avaient peur de se faire
engueuler dans la circonscription c'est
c'est possible c'est plus simple c'est
possible mais nous aussi nous nous
faisons engueuler dans nos
circonscriptions rassurez-vous les les
grands électeurs et les élus ne pas à
nous rappeler que si eux sont apportés
de baffe nous sommes à portée de leur
baffe donc c'est bien normal moi ce qui
me gêne plus si vous voulez dans ce
comportement dans cette discussion c'est
que la vraie force de la politique la
vraie noblesse de la politique c'est
aussi le courage il faut avoir le
courage de se présenter dans ses
lecteurs en gardant ses convictions et
que sur une réforme qui est aussi
importante que la réforme des retraites
Quentin une discussion qui mène à un
accord par un parti politique et battu
en brèche à la fin parce qu'on pourrait
avoir peur de ce qui va se passer le
dimanche suivant dans son sa
circonscription pose problème ça veut
dire que quelque part on est pas sur le
coup d'après on est sur ma propre
réélection le sujet c'est pas d'être élu
le sujet c'est de faire avancer la
France le sujet c'est d'être au service
de son pays avec toute l'humilité que ça
représente et donc quelque part il y a
un moment il faut du courage et il faut
dire ben non je ne suis pas d'accord
avec avec vous mes amis ou ceux qui sont
mes adversaires parce que je pense que
l'intérêt supérieur de la France est
assez endroit là et je l'assume donc je
pense que ça n'est pas tout à fait ce
sujet je crains plus que ce soit au sein
même du parti les républicains où il y a
une véritable difficulté c'est un parti
qui a qui a énormément souffert des
résultats des résultats aux élèves aux
différentes élections depuis les
élections municipales j'allais dire même
aux européennes
alors les anciens prisonniers ont monté
encore plus loin que moi mais ils ont eu
les élections municipales de 2020 qui
l'auront permis de d'espérer quelque
chose de Iron on va repartir et puis
tout le reste a été implanté
et tout le reste a été catastrophique
avec l'élection présidentielle telle
qu'on le sait et je crains fort qu'il
soit dans la même situation que la
gauche il y a un peu plus de 5 ans
maintenant dans une logique non pas
d'explosion mais d'implosion il faut pas
se tromper et quand on est en implosion
et qu'on croit que les événements sont
bouffer de l'extérieur et bien on se bat
en atteindre sans s'en rendre compte on
crée des frondeurs et on retrouve le
même fonctionnement aujourd'hui chez les
républicains que chez les socialistes il
y a 6 ans et ça c'est très inquiétant
parce que quelque part le parti ça fait
bien de l'intérieur et moi je considère
qu'une une belle démocratie est une
démocratie de controverse et donc on
puisse avoir des des adversaires et non
pas des ennemis à qui avec qui on puisse
discuter s'opposer confronter nos
positions et puis que l'alternance
puisse exister si les LRC fondent
aujourd'hui nous avons un véritable
problème puisqu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
partie démocratique républicains face à
nous c'est un dépollu on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure sur la violence
dans la société mais c'est vrai que
contrairement à ce qu'il pouvait se
passer par exemple quand il reforme des
retraites en 2010 c'est Sarkozy qui est
au pouvoir puis il y a une alternance
possible avec le passé-série aujourd'hui
il y a des oppositions mais on n'a pas
le sentiment qu'il y a des alternances
possibles c'est un peu le problème
les deux parties républicains au sens
noble du terme qui qui sont le parti
socialiste et qui sont les républicains
ou les centristes effectivement ça fait
plaisir mais ça fait plaisir de
l’intérieur moi je leur dis et je leur
redis faites très attention ça n'est pas
une explosion ça n'est pas du fait du
président de la République ou du fait de
renaissance ou du financement c'est un
problème interne de leur propre valeur
où il n'arrive plus à s'accorder entre
eux et c'est c'est ça voilà vous avez
quand même des quand vous les écoutez
des des différences d'approches et de
valeur profonde très forte si je prends
au moment de la présidentielle avant la
présidentielle une Valérie Pécresse ou
un ou un Xavier Bertrand versus un
François vous avez Bel-Ami ou un
on n'est pas tout à fait sur les mêmes
valeurs et quand on est dans le même
parti ça pose un problème ça pose un
véritable après mais je crois que leur
vrai problème il est là il faut qu'il
fasse le leur réflexion propre en
interne et leur réflexion intellectuelle
vraiment et qui retrouve un chemin qui
leur soit commun et cohérent et qui leur
permettent de reconstruire leur parti je
reviens vers ce que vous disiez tout
seul
paritaire et après vous dire c'est mal
passé plutôt mal passé vous auriez
préféré qu'on ait parcours au 49-3
je pense qu'à partir
du moment où il y a une commission mixte
paritaire qui a un accord en commission
paritaire je ne connais pas moi de mes
souvenirs de quoi ils sont mixte
paritaire qui se met d'accord et que
derrière une des deux chambres ne le
Vote pas C'est la première fois selon
moi que que cela arrive en tout cas du
mandat que j'ai parcouru c'est la seule
fois et bien évidemment tout le monde
aurait préféré que ce soit voté mais
quand qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important et c'est là c'est là où le
problème c'est fait qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important c'était la réforme la
réforme cette réforme à l'état
indispensable on pourra en parler à
l'occasion et pour nous elle est
considérer comme indispensable parce
qu'elle est sur le long terme donc quand
on est confronté à un mouvement à
l'Assemblée nationale ou la certitude
du navet positive et mise en jeu une
incertitude se fait forte jouer
l'incertitude au détriment d'une loi qui
se joue sur le temps long et qui est
pour les Français c'est pas imaginable
alors c'est pas la peine de faire la loi
donc il fallait que cette loi passe et
l'élément essentiel dans ces cas-là
c'est le 49-3 et je crois que le 49-3 a
une bien malheureusement une mauvaise
image parce que dans l'absolu c'est
peut-être le jour vraiment le mot
courage c'est une nouvelle fois un
article de très grand courage puisque on
dit cette loi est si importante pour le
gouvernement pour nous et pour la France
que non seulement en vous demandant de
voter le 49-3 on vous demande de voter
la loi telle qu'elle est mais surtout on
met en jeu le gouvernement notre
existence propre c'est d'une noblesse
excusez-moi face à côté j'irai presque
du panache du courage et du panache or
on prend ça comme quelque chose de
brutal oui c'est ça alors c'est
contraire
c'est je me mets devant vous tel que je
suis et vous avez le droit de me de me
détruire excusez-moi je trouve c'est
beaucoup plus proche du courage et du
panache que de la violence et de la
brutalité oui c'est vrai que c'est un
article alors maintenant on dit on
entend dire anti-démocratique il fait
partie quand même de la Constitution
donc utiliser une centaine de fois
donc
c'est très étonnant enfin cette espèce
de jeu si vous voulez quand on a plus
vraiment d'arguments on essaye cela et
comme à l'Assemblée nationale on est
quand même dans une logique non pas de
controverse mais d'affrontement et de
combat permanent on cherche toutes les
petits mots les petites failles qui
évitent d'organiser un débat dire 49-3
et crier 49-3 ça évite de discuter alors
on voit que la situation est quand même
bloquée il y a des manifestations qui
continuent les syndicats sont vont
debout contre le contre l'âge légal de
64 ans il va y avoir le 14 avril une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
est-ce que alors sans jouer les on peut
pas savoir ce que va dire le Conseil
constitutionnel mais ce qui est-ce que
ça peut constituer au fond une porte de
sortie cette crise de conseil
constitutionnel la première chose à dire
et je reprendrai à ma grande surprise ce
qui était dit ce matin par sur une
chaîne concurrente et néanmoins amis qui
est France Info que j'ai écouté ce matin
ils avaient invité un délégué syndical
Sud qui demandait aux conseils
constitutionnel de bien prendre en
compte l'état de la population
ça n'est pas le rôle du Conseil
le rôle de conseil constitutionnel c'est
de vérifier si cette loi correspond aux
critères imposés par la Constitution
c'est son seul rôle donc quand
sortira-t-il je ne le sais pas nous
avons voté une loi nous l'avons
travaillé énormément nous pensons donc
qu'elle correspond à la constitution
sinon on s'amuserait pas faire des lois
qui ne serait pas professionnel si on le
si on se trompe et ça peut arriver le
Conseil consuel et là mais c'est tout
donc est-ce qu'il y a une porte de
sortie ou pas je peux pas dire ça comme
ça le constitutionnel va émettre un avis
donner des préconisations mais
lesquelles on ne le sait pas et
peut-être qu'il y en aura pas donc pour
moi c'est pas une question de temps de
sortir c'est de savoir ce que Bada pour
cette console et effectivement s'il y a
un certain nombre de choses à revisiter
à retravailler mais faudra bien le faire
bien évidemment bien évidemment dans la
crise aussi qui qui se joue aujourd'hui
il y a une question de légitimité
Emmanuel Macron dit quelques enfin dans
son interview à
TF1 au trésor en tout cas
que la légitimité n'est pas dans la rue
elle est dans les institutions dans les
parlements mais en même temps
je pense que disait même le pied même
pierre rosanes il disait oui mais un
pouvoir qui coupait de la société ça ça
ne marche pas alors c'est vrai qu'à
cette ce combat de légitimité quoi qui
est qui pousse un problème je veux dire
que ce combat de légitimité existera
toujours à toujours exister mais il est
d'autant plus mis en avant par
l'accumulation des sondages permanents
en tous sens dans tous les sondage ne
fait pas ne fait pas la population c'est
le premier point et on ne gouverne pas
en fonction des sondages sinon on
n'avance pas
il peut arriver d'abord il y a une
élection majeure en France qui a voulu
le président qui a voulu le général le
Gaulle qui est l'élection du Président
de la République au suffrage universel
qui est quand même l'élément peut-être
le plus important de nos élections et
fondateurs effectivement de et c'était
il y a fort peu de temps c'était il y a
moins d'un an il y a moins d'un an au
premier tour puisque au premier tour le
premier tour est quand même un élément
important Emmanuel Macron a fait plus de
27% des voix 27% des voix c'est quand
même loin d'être légitimes très très il
y a bien longtemps en plus qu'en 2017
voilà et on a et il y a bien longtemps
qu'on n'a pas vu un candidat au premier
tour atteindre 27%. donc la légitimité
dans les 20%
une fois que j'ai dit ça comme principe
Emmanuel Macron s'est présenté à
l'époque avec un projet dans ce projet
il y avait la retraite à 65 ans
clairement affichée dire que ça ne
compte pas et que donc il pourrait être
illégitime parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
ne sont pas contents et que les sondages
disent qu'ils ne sont pas contents c'est
assez rocambolesque parce que derrière
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut absolument
plus gouverner faire de la politique
c'est bien la difficulté c'est ce moment
où l'on se doit de prendre des décisions
combien même elle ne serait pas
spécialement agréable si elles sont
importantes pour la nation et quand on
prend le régime des retraites qu'on dit
nous voulons sauver le régime par
répartition sauver le régime des
partition c'est sauver en fait une
logique sociale extraordinaire où il y a
une solidarité intergénérationnelle à
travers ce système on est les seuls au
monde où ce sont les actifs donc les
jeunes j'allais dire pour faire vite qui
cotisent
et ses cotisations servent à payer les
retraites de ceux qui sont en retraite
c'est une force extraordinaire mais donc
ça veut dire tout simplement que si on
est dans la logique du système par
répartition auquel tiennent énormément
les Français on doit rester dans le
système et les outils de manœuvre de ce
système sont pas nombreuses il dépendent
de la démographie et en fonction de la
démographie s'il a démographie tente à
donner de plus en plus non actifs il y a
plus beaucoup de possibilités il y a
soit augmenter les cotisations donc si
on augmente les cotisations il y a deux
possibilités les
salariales ou les patronales
salariales ça veut dire qu'on baisse le
net à payer aujourd'hui face à une
inflation telle qu'elle est un pouvoir
d'achat qui qui est difficile à
maintenir ça serait une très mauvaise
très mauvaise image de nez et ça ne
correspondrait absolument pas à ce qu'on
fait depuis 6 ans augmenter les
cotisations patronales ça voudrait dire
enchérir le coup du travail on est dans
une concurrence mondiale si aujourd'hui
notre économie s'en sort aussi bien et
beaucoup mieux d'autres pays après la
crise de la covid c'est justement parce
que nous avons une logique fiscale très
équilibrée depuis 5 ans et que
tout le monde nous en est reconnaissants
donc très mauvaise idée après on peut
baisser les pensions je pense que les
retraités ne seraient pas d'accord je
rappelle que nous l'avons fait en 2018
puisque nous avons augmenté la CSG sur
les retraités qui gagnent plus de 1000
euros oui mais c'était pourquoi c'était
par solidarité c'était en utilisant cet
outil là donc en baissant un peu les
pensions des retraités qui touchaient
plus de 2000 euros on a augmenté le net
à payer de tous les actifs de 3% c'est à
dire qu'on a redonné du pouvoir d'achat
aux actifs on a tenté de rééquilibrer un
peu se différencier entre actif et
inactif aujourd'hui recommencer à
baisser les pensions franchement ça
pouvait pas être donc il nous reste quoi
le temps le temps le temps de cotisation
et c'est bien pour ça que Emmanuel
Macron est parlé de 65 ans et que
l'évolution des discussions qui a pu
avoir a amener à 64 ans plus un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été
travaillées au Sénat et donc c'était
essentiel si vous voulez si on veut
sauver le régime par des partitions
c'était là et là où je suis très embêté
c'est que si je reprends ce que demande
les syndicats depuis le début ils disent
non à l'allongement de la durée du
travail
totalement contre l'allongement elle est
contre la
contre l'âge
je me suis mal exprimé les contre là je
les garde
Emmanuel Macron je le rappelle a été élu
sur une idée des 65 nous ça parle le
compromis par le travail par le nous
sommes arrivés à 64 ans plus un certain
nombre de mesures très nombreuses sur la
pénibilité sur l'égalité femme homme sur
les seniors sur un certain nombre de
choses travailler avec les syndicats
pendant trois mois ça n'a pas été tandis
que ça mais c'est pourtant ce qui s'est
passé qui ont considérablement fait
évoluer cette loi donc du coup tu es du
gouvernement les évolutions étaient très
importantes du côté des syndicats
excusez moi il y a eu zéro évolution
mais zéro
de mon côté en tant que que démocrate et
républicain je suis ouvert à toutes les
discussions possibles mais il faut quand
on fait une véritable discussion
j'allais dire que pour trouver la bonne
solution faut d'abord bien poser le
problème si le problème est mal posé
vous aurez plusieurs solutions et des
mauvaises solutions
nous avons nous sommes partis du
postulat à nous dans la problématique
que le système para répartition était en
cause et qu'il fallait sauver le cm par
répartition c'est notre point de départ
si le point de départ n'est pas celui-là
effectivement on pouvait discuter avec
les syndicats on aurait pu dire oui
remettons en cause le système par
répartition et taxons le capital c'est
parce que c'est les communistes par
exemple ça c'est souvent je dis oui
c'est un sujet qu'on pourrait aborder
mais dans ces cas-là il faudrait que les
communistes les socialistes les verts et
tous ceux qui sont contre tous les
syndicats disent clairement qu'ils
veulent remettre en cause c'est par
répartition ce qu'il ne font jamais ils
sont les premiers à dire nous devons
sauver le régime par répartition et
derrière toutes les propositions qu'ils
font sans le dire mettent à mal le
régime par répartition donc il faut être
cohérent moi si les syndicats demain me
disent oui je suis prêt à remettre en
cause le régime par répartition et bien
ça ouvre d'autres types de possibilités
mais il faut le dire aux Français les
Français quand vous leur dites
capitalisation ils sont pas toujours
spécialement convaincus donc ça
demandera du temps de conviction aussi
croyez-moi
je reviens à ce dont on parlait
c'est-à-dire des crises au four de
légitimité on voit tout est remis en
cause les résultats des élections enfin
de la chance sans cesse il y a beaucoup
de menaces il y a votre collègue
Auberger
voilà
je crois déjà démissionné depuis 2022
sur les
démissions des maires il y en a un peu
plus de je peux pas vous dire une bêtise
mais un peu plus de 1000 ou 2000 depuis
2020 si on compare à la période d'avant
on est à peu près dans la dans le même
pourcentage et à ce pourcentage il faut
tenir compte d'une grande difficulté qui
a été la pandémie avec l'élection des
maires souvenez-vous en plein pendant la
pandémie et donc il y a un certain
nombre de maires qu'on démissionné très
rapidement à ce moment-là parce qu'ils
étaient ils arrivaient j'allais dire
pour la première fois en tant que mère
ils se sont retrouvés dans des
situations absolument incompréhensible
pour eux et c'est un certain nombre
démission à ce moment là donc
globalement on est dans les mêmes
chiffres d'accord moins
importants
leur mise en cause est-ce que au fond
parce qu'on a toujours l'impression que
la démocratie c'est un régime qui est là
pour toujours
est-ce que est-ce qu'on devrait pas être
inquiet justement pour la démocratie la
démocratie
ce qui s'est passé à sainte-solide peu
importe peut-être des deux côtés là mais
mais
la démocratie est une fleur de toute
beauté donc elle est fragile elle est
toujours fragile et comme chez nous elle
existe depuis longtemps on s'y est
tellement habitué qu'on a oublié sa
fragilité et il y a un petit jeu mais il
n'y a pas qu'en France mais souvent en
France d'anti parlementarisme par
exemple très puissant très fort ou on se
gaussent des de l'hémicycle à moitié
vide où on se Gause d'un sénateur ou
d'un député qui s'est endormi où on se
Gause de de l'absence de travail de
pseudo chauffeur que nous n'avons pas
enfin bon de tas d'histoires autour de
ce régime
on pourra en parler
le président Larcher dans l'opposition
donc c'est facile pour moi c'est là de
ne pas vous répondre je vais vous
répondre ce que je pense que tu
reviendras on reviendra parce que j'ai
beaucoup plus important que vous ayez
posé mais sur le régime des retraites du
Sénat le président de Larcher a dit qui
était un sujet qu'il allait travailler
d'accord donc j'ai pas d'inquiétude de
ce côté-là et sur le fond je dis juste
un petit truc sur le sur le sur le
système de retrait du snap parce que je
me suis un petit peu intéressé à cause
de ça récemment parce que je vous avoue
que je mets je m'étais pas vraiment
intéressé à la chose
il est limité le système c'est un
système avec un montant que je sais pas
comment il est calculé d'ailleurs peu
importe d'abord nous avons une double
cotisation à l'inverse des autres donc
c'est un système qui n'est pas
spécifique mais qui est un système euh
propre au Sénat et ça fonctionne pour
demander si vous faites trois quatre
mandats ça ne contracte que deux mandats
qui comptent il faut le savoir et en
général la moyenne je crois de départ en
retrait des sénateurs et au-delà de 72
ans ce qui fait que la caisse du Sénat
est très riche entre guillemets parce
qu'en fait les sénateurs ne prennent pas
beaucoup de retraite ne vivent pas
longtemps dans leur retraite pas cher
démocratie moi je pense aussi qu'elle
est liée à cette image permanente qu'on
donne du parlementaire où on nous donne
le sentiment qui a pas longtemps notre
travail pas
les missiles alors que le travail que
nous faisons et finalement relativement
peu à l'hémicycle nous travaillons par
commission d'abord donc il y a c'est là
il y a cette commission moi je suis la
commission des affaires sociales donc il
traite tout ce qui est social tout ce
qui est énorme tout ce qui est santé
parce que tout ce qui est santé tout ce
qui est retraite tout ce qui est droit
du travail tout ce qui est formation
apprentissage et formation donc vous
voyez le panel des lois qui peuvent
passer dans cette dans cette commission
qui sont étudiées et quand nous les
étudions en commission ou que nous
faisons des auditions nous recevons des
spécialistes et on le fait énormément
pour bien sentir justement comment faire
évoluer une loi ou comment faire
soi-même une loi mais tout ce travail ne
se voit pas et c'est bien naturel et
quand on le fait on n'est pas
l'hémicycle ou à l'hémicycle il se passe
autre chose il y a les lois continuent
de voter une loi donc
par exemple je n'y étais pas parce que
je travaillais sur le système de santé
et mais je travaillais et ça les
Français ne le savent pas parce qu'on
préfère montrer du parlementaire les
petits 3% de choses qui ne vont pas mais
mais honnêtement je et j'en suis et je
lis très vite très bien je travaille au
moins 70 heures par semaine et ça me va
très bien la mise en cause de répondu de
la légitimité maintenant enfin voilà on
dit Macron et ben oui il fallait pas été
lui il était élu parce qu'il était
déjà des premiers tours je vous rappelle
le 27% et ensuite moi la légitimité ce
que je réponds aux gens qui me disent
ils sont légitime
et après vous comprendrez ce que veut
dire légitime parce que ce pré-entérieux
c'est très facile de critiquer un
parlementaire c'est très facile de
critiquer un merci très facile de
critiquer un président de la République
mais se présentait à une élection et
pourquoi il y a finalement si peu de
gens qui se présentent aux élections
c'est parce que c'est quelque chose de
très compliqué vous mettez totalement à
nu devant devant les électeurs et c'est
bien naturel
mais c'est une violence incroyable c'est
très compliqué mais bien sûr et c'est
bien normal et c'est tout à fait normal
c'est très difficile et en plus vous
vous lancez pour un CDD qui n'est pas
obligatoirement renouvelable on n'est
pas élu à vie et donc donc on vit une
période enfin si je prends mon exemple
moi je viens je suis pas un homme
politique de la base je viens je viens
du secteur privé je me présente en 2017
pour la première fois au Sénégal je suis
élu mais ça veut dire que je mets de
côté mon travail privé donc j'arrête
complètement de l'activité de salariés
si je ne représente pas aussi je ne suis
pas élu
excusez-moi mais j'ai mis mon jeu j'ai
mis tout ça dans la balance j'aurais 61
ans à 61 ans c'est pas si simple que ça
de retrouver du travail en plus vous
avez une jolie étiquette sur le front
ancienne homme politique
donc c'est pas aussi simple ça demande
une force de conviction derrière qui est
très importante et je crois que vraiment
on ne se rend pas compte de ce que fait
le parlementaire du travail qu'il fait
et qu'il doit faire parce qu'il s'agit
de dire je suis merveilleux c'est pas du
tout ce sujet je nous avons beaucoup de
travail et bien heureusement et c'est
très important et quand on fait une loi
et notre rôle c'est d'étudier au maximum
tous les arguments des pour et des
comptes qui font évoluer notre propre
argumentaire à nous c'est essentiel moi
il m'est arrivé de changer d'avis sur un
certain nombre d'amendements on peut
changer d'avis mais bien sûr et
heureusement et heureusement je reviens
crise politique aussi
Emmanuel Macron a donné à la première
vie c'est des événements de la mission
d'élargir la majorité ils ont pas être
facile parce qu'on voit quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé à LR on parle aussi de
remaniement et on parle par exemple de
du président du Sénat enfin il y a un
bruit qui envoie le Gérard Larcher à
Matignon
est-ce que ça serait une bonne idée et
deux est-ce que Emmanuel Macron n'aurait
pas quand même intérêt à s'entourer plus
de politique enfin de gens qui
connaissent les territoires la politique
jusqu'à présent alors plusieurs
plusieurs éléments de réponse le premier
c'est
comment élargir la majorité la première
difficulté c'est qu'il y avait deux
possibilités au départ c'était soit
faire une coalition qui a été refusé par
tous les autres partis politiques donc
et qui ont tous dit à ce moment-là on va
travailler texte par texte très bien ça
a plutôt bien fonctionné au début
puisqu'il y a quand même une vingtaine
de lois qui ont été votées et pas des
moindres jusqu'à maintenant dans cette
logique donc du coup par coup
pas du loi par loi ce coût parcours ça
peut être interprété autrement du doigt
par loi et puis est arrivé les retraites
où là il y avait un accord de principe
mais cet accord a été battu en brèche
c'est la première fois sur une loi
excessivement importante et sur une loi
je le répète de courage parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas avec une voix
comme ça qu'on se fait réélire
je crois que c'est important que les
Français le comprennent de surdité aussi
on peut on peut le on peut entendre ça
aussi mais il faut bien comprendre que
ce qui a manqué à la France depuis 30
ans selon moi c'est justement le courage
on a eu beaucoup de qui ont été faites
juste pour être élu et pas pour aller
beaucoup plus loin nous nous avons vu
d'être sur les références ou de recul
sur les ventes ce qui est encore mieux
euh ce qui pour moi est encore pire sauf
si on s'est vraiment trompé c'était pas
le cas donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut redonner aussi au sens politique ce
courage là afficher son courage et dire
oui je sais que ce que je vous demande
est un effort peut-être que nous n'avons
très mal présenté ça c'est possible moi
je pense que on aurait dû dire au
français oui on vous demande un effort
oui vraiment l'assumer on vous demande
un effort ça n'est pas facile pour
certains d'entre vous on le sait mais
c'est ce qui sauvera notre régime on a
voulu dire que c'était justice sociale
etc etc ces mots-là quand on demande un
efforts
c'est comme expliqué que 2 + 2 = 4 on
peut enfin
moi le premier des erreurs de
communications du bon sens quelqu'un qui
travaille à mi-temps ne peut pas gagner
1200 euros vas-y gagner 700 euros vous
voyez enfin bon être obligé de
réexpliquer que depuis des
erreurs de
absolument donc moi c'est mon premier
point c'est le courage et c'est donc
avoir en face de soi pour faire une
coalition ou pour faire des accords au
coup par coup des partis politiques en
face qui ont ce courage là aussi on a vu
que pour les retraites ça n'est pas
arrivé sur une question de méthode
est-ce que ça aurait pas été plus simple
de mettre cette retraite dans un grand
ensemble de travail puisqu'il y a on
voit bien que le rapport au travail le
rapport au travail était en train de
changer qui est peut-être des des des
questions à menées sur le temps de
travail
de quatre jours enfin ce sont des vrais
sujets sur lesquels je travaille depuis
longtemps en plus mais et derrière ça on
nous a d'abord reproché de pas faire les
lois dans le bon ordre et donc on aurait
dû au premier reproche les retraites
vous avez dû le faire après la réflexion
sur le travail moi je rappelle que ces
reproches on nous les a fait aussi en
quand la première réforme qu'on a faite
et même les deux premières ça a été les
amendements de travail donc la loi sur
le travail on a réformé totalement le
droit du travail et la loi sur
l'apprentissage et la formation on nous
a dit qu'on faisait tout à l'envers et
qu'il fallait d'abord s'inquiéter du
chômage et qu'ensuite on pouvait
réformer le travail et nous on a
expliqué que pas du tout on avait cette
cohérence et qu'on allait faire baisser
le chômage c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé et pour les retraites c'est la
même chose les retraites c'était de dire
on a un système qui est en danger qui
est un système de solidarité on n'a pas
assez rappelé aux Français ce principe
de le secondarité moi je crois que si
les Français reprenaient la mesure de
cette solidarité de cette force qui est
les actifs travaillent pour cotiser pour
les CEVA pour que les retraites se payer
par leurs cotisation et qui prennent
conscience aussi que si ça se
déséquilibre à un moment ça cassera et
que ça sera très mauvais choix pour l'un
soit pour l'autre un jour un jeune
président Emmanuel Macron et jeune mais
lui croire au système par répartition
mais dans 10 ans un jeune président élu
ou une jeune président élu dit ça marche
plus système ce sont les retraités en
place qui vont très très cher donc
attention attention quand on dit on vous
protège c'est du très long terme et
c'est pour ça qu'il fallait beaucoup de
courage pour faire cette réforme de long
terme on l'a peut-être mal dit et c'est
pour ça que j'insiste sur l'ordre il
était important de commencer par l'autre
la retraite pour redonner le sens au
travail et parler ensuite du travail et
de ce logique parce que moi je crois
beaucoup à l'effort je crois beaucoup à
la réussite par le travail et je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup de moyens vous parlez
la semaine des quatre jours c'est un
travail sur lequel j'ai énormément
travaillé puisque dans des accords que
j'ai pu faire j'ai pas joué sur les
quatre jours mais j'ai joué sur des
congés plus longs et pour travailler
plus dans la semaine donc ça revenait un
peu à ça de temps de travail pour donner
plus de congés
auditionné par exemple le une société
dont je vais faire la publicité mais
c'est pas grave ça s'appelle LDLC qui
est une société qui vend du matériel
enfin qui vend des au départ qui a
commencé comme ça du matériel
informatique par internet au tout début
comme Rue du Commerce ou d'autres et qui
aujourd'hui continue sur ce coeur de
métier mais a aussi des boutiques 80
boutiques plus de 1000 salariés
aujourd'hui il y a trois ou quatre ans
le président directeur a décidé de
passer au 32 heures par semaine mais
travailler 4 jours par semaine en se
disant pour bien travailler 4 jours je
fais 32 heures je les paierai 35 il y a
eu un une levée de bouclier des
syndicats il faut le savoir qui n'était
pas d'accord parce qu'ils ont eu peur
ils partent du principe qu'un patron
obligatoirement c'était c'est que ce
regard permanent du finalement il y est
arrivé il avait provisionné mis de côté
j'allais dire des sous pour embaucher
pour compenser les trois heures qui
manquaient par semaine par salarié par
1000 salariés vous voyez il n'a embauché
personne ce qui veut bien dire que quand
on crée des conditions intelligentes
bien travaillé ensemble et c'est au cas
par cas il y a pas il faut pas faire de
loi autour de ça mais au cas par cas par
accord d'entreprise on est capable
d'augmenter la productivité des gens à
partir du moment il en retrouve eux une
autre qualité voilà il s'agit croit
énormément et je crois que la relation
qu'on doit avoir au travail c'est aussi
celle là c'est d'abord considéré que
nous sommes pas des machines donc notre
travail n'est pas linéaire il y a et
heureusement donc il y a ce vrai débat
qui est passionnant mais il fallait
traiter les retraites en amont pour pour
que ça ne pollue pas et ça ne perturbe
pas ce sujet là essentiel
à travers ce sujet vous avez aussi
justement le télétravail vous avez une
nouvelle approche du travail de la
familiale parfois un mélange des deux
qui demande beaucoup de réflexion et
donc le moins de scories possible ou de
d'interférences possibles sur des choses
qui sont plus figées et la retraite fait
partie des choses qui sont figées parce
que c'est un arrêt du travail
malheureusement
si vous n'avez importante pour les le
sais pas parce qu'il y a un
renouvellementier et d'eau des élections
dans les Yvelines vous serez candidats
oui
les autres sont connus enfin il existe
et nous en tant que sénateur comme notre
rôle c'est de travailler 6 absolument
donc les listes et les listes c'est donc
un système par liste avec eux et vous
devez présenter 6 candidats plus de deux
suppléments huit personnes qui sont pas
la même chose
dans les élus directs je crois 10
députés 12 enfin
et dans les sénateurs vous êtes le seul
absolument sur six députés des cinq
autres
là vous espérez entre 1 et 6 si vous
voulez tout savoir
donc je ne fais jamais de de
perspective de prospective sur ce genre
de sujet parce que d'avoir une élection
est toujours unique et une élection est
toujours importante une élection se fait
aussi sur les personnes
par exemple avec le but
on a créé un groupe alors il y a vous
avez Renaissance horizon et le MoDem qui
ont créé une famille entre guillemets
ensemble et j'espère bien et je compte
bien puisque le président Macron nous a
demandé de faire ça il a il a demandé à
ce que tous les sortants
soit des têtes de liste tous les
sénateurs sortants qu'ils soient
horizons qu'ils soient Renaissance ou
qu'il soit moderne donc on est grosso
modo une vingtaine de sortants sur toute
la France entre horizon
pour mémoire en 2017 il n'y a eu que 8
sénateurs élus sous l'étiquette la
République en marche sur toute la France
j'en faisais partie face à Gérard
Larcher c'est quand même une belle
fierté de ma part donc j'en suis très
fier d'ailleurs mais bon ça demande
beaucoup d'humidité ça derrière mais
effectivement donc on est une vingtaine
de sortants à peu près donc il était
cohérent que ces 20 là soient reconduits
comme tête de liste et que sur les 100
60 150 circonscriptions ou départements
restantes il y a une discussion que je
mets plus à un horizon
au sénatorial c'est toujours des
histoires compliquées vous parliez 2017
en 2012 il y a eu je crois 12 listes en
2017 onze dans le département donc c'est
toujours il y a un sentiment il y a des
gens qui sont persuadés
en tout cas en 2017 il y en avait au
moins cinq qui se qui se représentaient
sous la l'étiquette majorité
présidentielle ce qui était assez
cocasse bien sûr
voilà donc voilà non mais ça c'est assez
naturel et j'allais dire c'est moi je
suis toujours admiratif des gens qui se
présentent parce que se présenter une
élection je vous promets que ça demande
beaucoup d'humidité et beaucoup de
volonté et c'est très bien
je vous cache pas que moi je suis très
très heureux de très heureux des cinq
ans que j'ai 5 ans et demi que j'ai
passé et très fier d'avoir été élu et
très heureux d'avoir d'avoir je crois
été utile à mon pays et si je me
représente c'est parce que je crois que
je peux encore être utile à mon pays
c'est ce qui m'apporte le plus dans
cette histoire et demanda ça vous
permettra de cotiser pour la retraite
si je fais de mandat ça tombe bien merci
beaucoup en attendant puisque sur un
point c'est que je ne cotisie plus à
l'agir Carco d'accord et donc je vais
perdre mon salaire du privé je vais
perdre l'air de rien
des sommes aussi donc il faut faire
attention à ces sujets qui sont beaucoup
plus complexe qu'on ne le croit merci
beaucoup Martin lévrier un grand merci à
vous
[Musique]